Uh, what up everybody? I'm Andrew Schultz. And I'm going to answer the internet.
Um.
You get to have sex with the girl of your dreams,
but they hold a press conference after rating your sexual performance.
Do you do it? Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah, no, I go on my back. I just,
I that's what I do. That's the only way I can control it.
I just go on my back and then I let her ride it. And then I put the hooks in.
If I can get the hooks in dude. And I just a little rock a baby.
I think I can handle. I can be okay. And some deep breaths.
And I look at the ceiling and I count the boogers on my wall. That's how I last,
I looked at the ceiling. I count my bulgur wall and I get the rocks.
And if I get the hooks, then we can have some fun. She says whatever she wants.
And when it's my time to finish Ben Dover, four strokes gamer.
You're done. Right? I'm done. I'm done. Whenever you're done. Just let me know.
Cause it's over four strokes. If it takes any longer than that,
then you get to do some giggles. All right.
You can read the text message history between two people. Who do you pick?
Oh man. Ooh. Yeah.
Yeah. I was thinking Trump and Cohen, but uh, I don't know enough about it,
but that one would probably be pretty lit. You know what I mean? Like, yeah.
You gave her a hundred. K the. You kidding me?
She's a.
Did 20 grand to see settle it.
10 stupid hundred grand.
I said she got to me. Okay.
Would you rather be the smartest person every time you walk in the room or the
best looking person? Every time you walk in the room? Um,
so here's the thing I rent.
I don't care about being the best looking person that walks in the room,
but I also don't want to be the smartest because then how are you learning
anything? So this is a very tough one, but it's one or the other.
I'd probably, I guess be the smartest person every time I walk in the room.
Yeah. That's how I feel in an Uber pool.
I'm like, what am I doing with these pedestrians? Why did I even do this?
Just kidding. I don't do that. [inaudible] what am I bored?
Would you rather have a dog's personality in a cat body or a cat's
personality in a dog's body dude,
animal trainees are crazy.
This is what's up about it.
I'd rather have a dog's personality and a cat body without a doubt.
Right? That'd be so fun. That's what we want in cats. We don't really want dogs.
The body's kind of. Right? The cat. Body's great. It's nimble.
You just throw them they land. Yeah, you can. If the cat's really good,
you know, it's, it's one of those things like.
Um, uh, you know, it's like, you basically, it's like,
you're a guy in a bar and every girl is looking at you. Like
[inaudible].
I liked the way you went with it. I went with like the autistic kid. It is a,
you know, works on the high school basketball team or whatever. And then like,
he's a little weird. And then he hits that corner three,
the last game of the year. And you're like, it's Sean. I knew I loved this guy,
bro. That's a shining moment.
They never play those videos where he misses every shot.
And then a coach just takes them out. All right. He gave you 11 shots, buddy.
I don't know what you want to do it. I'd go ahead.
He's shooting at the bleachers. Would you rather have to eat all the hair?
Every time you get a haircut or eat all the fingernails?
Every time you clip your nails, you guys don't eat. Those
do not eat the fingernails in a heartbeat. Absolutely. Even the hair is crazy,
but fingernails, I could do that. I bite my toenails. I bite my toenails.
And when the big toe is thick, it's like a thick nail. Right.
And when I, if I get it off in one piece,
I just use it as a toothpick for a little while. Just like watch some TV.
I like pick I'll chew on it. Yeah. Absolutely.
Hundred percent serious at look, I get my foot up there.
I was going to say, prove it.
Maybe the most disgusting thing I've ever. Yeah. But it's nice. You need that.
And it's your work? I like admiring the work. You know what I mean? It's like.
Get a piece of tree and little down a toothpaste. No.
It's not about the toothpick. It's just like, I did that. Like that's mine.
Like I did like, it's like, when you like calm, right?
It's like you don't wash it down right away. You're just kinda like, ah,
you know, you just want to look a little bit,
and then you just in the shower with your foot,
would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick or
sit on a Dick and either kick
yo you know what? This depends. How big the Dick and cake are. Right?
Like if it's a small Dick, like if it's,
if it's like half a pinky, right? That's a thorough wipe.
That's not even really sex. Do you know what I mean?
Like I'm going deeper in there to get Dingleberry. So if it's a small Dick,
I'd rather sit on the Dick and then eat a cake.
It doesn't matter the size of cake. Right? It's gonna be slight discomfort.
It's like carrying a shank into prison. It's not even gay.
I'm just protecting myself
without a doubt. I'm not eating a Dick. That's nuts.
Would you rather, every time you come, it comes out of your mouth
or it's a two liter bottles worth. Whoa, buddy.
Well, let me tell you something.
Give me the two liter would be incredible.
Are you kidding me?
But what do you think about it? Like what about when you're just like,
like you're, you're up. It's 2:00 AM. You're trying to fall asleep. You guys.
Open the window.
It's going to be some inclement weather in grammar this evening.
[inaudible] real. Talk to leaders. Let's go, man.
I'd like to not in the condom and just watch a balloon out.
Would you rather go to jail for one year or go to jail with a Rubik's cube and
you can leave when it's done. Give me a year. Okay. Give me a year.
I'm on good behavior. I'm out at nine months.
There's no way I'm solving a Rubik's cube. Okay. I'm Caucasian.
Okay. I don't know if you've seen the YouTube videos. No,
a lot of guys like me figured that out.
Could I make myself Chinese before? Because that would change a lot. Thanks
dude. You wouldn't even close the door. Sure.
If your belly button was a real button and you could push it once a day to
make anything happen, what would you do? I mean, the right thing is obviously,
you know, drop food over East Africa. But, um,
what I would do is like a gust of wind would just come by.
If a girl was born skirt,
[inaudible], don't put that.
[inaudible] all due respect, you know, others back then
I have a choice between world peace and a sum of money.
How high does that amount of money needs to be? Uh, for me to say, world peace.
Uh, you know what I like about this question is, uh,
you know that there's an amount it's not either or it's
it already bakes in? What's the number. Yes. Um, yeah. It's like,
cause like world peace, like, do we even want well paced? Like what?
Think about all the jobs that will be lost. If we have world peace,
like you gotta really think about world. Peace is going to destroy the economy.
There's going to be people hungry all over the place. Yeah. We're peaceful.
But you starve to death, you know? There's no news anymore. News is gone.
My job as a comedian, I can't be a comedian.
If nothing's happening in the world, 50 bucks,
I think 50 bucks. I'll take it just so we don't have world peace.
That's the last thing we need right now. If I'm being selfish, I got one life.
I don't want to be kumbaya for the rest of it. No, I would. I mean, look,
I'd probably say a lot more, but it would be, you know,
it would be like Kaepernick with the NFL. It'd be like, he'd be like,
I want a hundred million. They're like five it. Okay.
Okay.
Would you rather be able to eat as much as you want without getting fat or never
have to be pay for a meal again? No. As much as I want without getting fat.
Are you kidding me without a doubt? No question. I'm ready.
I don't know if you've know that yet guys. I'm wealthy. Okay.
Am I out of focus? Bring it back. I'm rich. Okay.
Uber black sometimes. All right.
If it's not surcharge and I'm going to LaGuardia instead of JFK. All right,
Dave Guedes eggs. My point is bring on the carbs.
I'm eating cake, whether I'm sitting on a Dick or not.
Okay. Would you rather wake up every morning to a or $100 under your pillow?
$100 under my pillow, without a doubt, without a doubt,
I don't have that highest sex drive that I need. My Dick sucked every morning.
Matter of fact, it's more of a nuisance at times.
There are moments where a girl is playing with my soft
Dick in the morning that I know is not going to get hard.
And there is nothing more masculine waiting than when she just
stops playing with it and then taps it a couple times ago.
Okay.
So give me the Benjamin.
Thank you so much, man.